for this TEDx talk I was supposed to
have an outline done by the beginning in
January and a first draft done of the
talk by mid January is January 21st now
and I have neither 2018 I was approached
to give a TEDx talk at the University of
Pennsylvania I mean what an honor so
obviously I said yes but I also decided
to film the entire process so that we
can give you guys a behind-the-scenes
look on what it's actually like to give
a TED talk I mean how hard can it be
mornin morning Nick is Monday I have a
call in 15 minutes with the organizers
of the TEDx events and the talk is in a
little less than two months and I'm
worried that it's not gonna go well
because turns out writing a TED talk is
a lot harder than I originally thought
it would be what I pitched was what
makes visual effects bad when are V
effects bad so here I am pitching a talk
about the thing that I have a lot of
technical experience with about how
stuff in movies from people far more
talented than I am how what they do
sucks that kinda just goes against my
personality I don't really like talking
about how things are bad even the poor
work that I've done I'm still proud of
to a certain degree because it took
effort I don't know man I think there's
gonna be about like a thousand people in
attendance never done that I got up
early this morning to hoping to just
like bang out script and I ended up just
kind of banging out a whole bunch of
random ideas that I've just been shocked
and blasted onto a piece of paper oh
here we go hey how's it going
uh okay so this is proving to be way
more challenging to write than I
initially anticipated I've got tons of
ideas but my challenge right now is kind
of focusing those ideas into something
that has a cohesive point great talk to
you later
the next step to all this is to actually
write and they're gonna help me with
that but first I need to get all of my
ideas for all the different directions
this talk can go in onto paper
[Music]
3:30 a.m. I finished my second draft
came out to five pages
[Music]
this is like my first draft we have this
problem here in the studio where all
right one needs to decide to start
trying to film something everyone jumps
out of the woodwork I'm gonna get out of
this spot t-minus 12 days till the talk
I mean I'm getting off this crafts hold
up the number-one fear of people is
public speaking there's a big difference
between a camera and a sea of people if
it makes you feel better there will be
cameras there I'm really nervous about
this I pretty much never talk about it
but I get panic attacks every now and
then I I have anxiety issues my wife is
actually the one who bears the brunt of
most of that stuff because it's usually
at home when I'm freaking out at 1 in
the morning that I still haven't gotten
a script finished and so I have to like
physically tell myself that it will be
okay
so I've literally like made notes oh God
I am super humbled and honored that I
have this opportunity to do a TED talk
but I am so looking forward to all this
being done did Ren you're talking todays
dude no it's in three days yeah it's in
three days three days excited your smile
is way too evil right now Nick I spent
the weekend finalizing my script and I
started working on the slideshow I ended
up having to work all night to work on
it
I like three and a half hours of sleep
as of now visuals are 100% done my
script is 100% done but the problem is
that I have like two and a half days to
memorize five pages of words I looked at
images of the actual auditorium
I can't wait to see the TED talk dude
I'm gonna be up on the stage with all
the people's awesome and all the lights
on there I plan for memorizing is I'm
gonna go to the store I'm gonna buy a
notebook and I'm gonna fill every page
of paper with my script just writing the
same paragraph over and over and over
again I found myself being able to
remember my script better having written
it out by hand and then doing it again
and again I went through the entire
script with the presentation with my
wife last night there's a pretty strict
15-minute time limit on your talk trying
to sync up what you're saying what
changing to the next slide is
challenging okay so it's the end of the
day we got to get to the airport this
entire region what happened this
happened like so I was riding along and
I was doing something I shouldn't have
been doing I was on my phone
Oh cuz I was going to get my shoes
cleaned and I was like I need the Google
Maps where I'm going so I pulled I was
like should I take this street or not
and I hit a pothole
so I landed on the ground like this with
all my force hitting my thigh two days
before your TED talk at least I didn't
break anything
do and my fingers
[Music]
it is Friday March 15th and tomorrow is
my actual TEDx talk at UPenn this is
gonna be my first attempted rehearsal or
without the script what mood
computer-generated imagery has left for
a massive range of new stories to be
told through movies and TV we're heading
to the Erb I nodded to him to do the
dress rehearsal for real this time
I'm a little worried because I didn't
realize how unprepared with the second
half I was now I have to warn them ahead
of time like I have pretty much the
entire team expertly memorized but I
don't have like the ordering I know
everything to say but I don't know when
to say it in I'm really worried about
that don't make us understand that do
the rehearsal we had in the hotel room
went so much better every single
paragraph I said I choked after it
that's a terrible feeling because I feel
like I already know the content of what
I'm trying to say well enough my problem
is that I don't know what to say next
and I freeze and I choke and when I
choke I get even more nervous and I
realize that I'm messing up it's just a
disaster I gotta work harder it's no I
got it I got to work I got to work
smarter and also harder
[Music]
so apparently I can actually use notes
on each of my slides from my
presentations I went ahead and I just
tried to write basically just like
memory cues I think I might have been
saved I ended up kind of delivering
these a little late but what's new in my
life so what I want to do now is I want
to just do a run-through where I pretend
to click through the slides but the only
notes I'm gonna have are basically just
this and introducing Ren Waichman
computer-generated imagery or CGI has
allowed for a massive range of new
stories to be told through movies and TV
shows
black holes dragons superheroes oh my
like all forms of art quality comes down
to skill and time no phil has ever
finished it just gets released they pour
blood sweat and tears into these stories
that capture our imaginations thank you
[Applause]
15:44 ah dang it dang tell you tired
turn it I think you should just do it
all one more time I feel bad for you
Nick that you're having to listen to
this over and over again oh yeah I mean
obviously I'm gonna have to do it many
times but I think you're right I'm gonna
actually stand outside the stadium and
deliver deliver my TED talk
[Laughter]
[Music]
I think I'm ready I think I'm ready
I'm not ready oh god I'm ready get
pumped up get excited get ready it's
gonna be really really great there's
nothing more I can do to prepare right
now to make it better so at this point
why worry about that yes I feel like
resigned to whatever's gonna happen and
that's calming
[Music]
thank you so much for helping me through
this man yeah but really first it's my
blood
[Applause]
[Music]
there's a common misconception regarding
how CGI is created people tend to think
effects are just made by computers
rather than actual people but here's the
thing great visual effects are about
more than just technical ability they
need to have artistic expression as well
I'm hesitant to openly criticize the
effects of the movie because a lot of
overworked artists help create them and
I think about those artists a lot take a
moment to appreciate all of the hard
work that went unnoticed visual effects
artists are artists after all
they put blood sweat and tears into
these stories that capture our
imaginations and sometimes their best
work may have been invisible all along
[Music]
thank you so much
[Applause]
[Music]
well although after I said my first line
I licked my lips and realized I have no
moisture in my mouth I'm on the verge of
tears right now man like completing it
like I haven't having like the audience
laugh at all the right moments to not
mess up or choke at any point okay now I
actually I'm tearing up so my emotions
are just like clipping their values
right now so I'm just kind of I gotta
like handle that I expected to feel
complete and utter relief but that's not
even remotely what I feel right now I
feel pure ecstatic meant and excitement
and energy so many people came here I
thought there was gonna be ten people I
heard you call minecraft earlier
I'm never safe I know the places that go
wear and tear in the places that do not
that was one of the most challenging but
most rewarding experiences of my entire
life so a huge thanks to the TEDx Penn
Organization for having me and Nick on
documenting the entire thing it was a
really really cool experience and the
talk itself will be up at some point I
don't know when but in the meantime we
actually realized the content of my talk
makes for a great video essay so we went
ahead and made one and it's already up
online right now you can go check it out
thanks for watching this thanks for
sticking on through this whole journey
until next time thanks for watching